hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the absolutely crazy
revelations from the latest installment
of the black clover story
the presumed vice captain of the black
bulls the secret black bull who had
infiltrated the spade kingdom as a spy
has revealed himself to asta and
this person's magic is even more
overpowered than we possibly could have
imagined when we first saw them
back in the spade kingdom these new
revelations
just changed everything things are
absolutely insane right now
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
black lover content on this channel you
want us to keep it going please slap a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications the only way to make
sure that you're not gonna miss our
black clover content
is to go through the trouble of hitting
that bell and selecting the option that
says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will of
course contain
black clover manga spoilers we are
talking about the most recent events
in the manga so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned the new chapter
starts off with asta and the black bulls
back inside the clover kingdom after the
big fight against
dante and after the tragic abductions of
yami and william owen the wizard king's
healer
is examining asta in the aftermath of
the dante fight
and even though asta's life is
thankfully not in danger
owen doesn't know what to do about
asta's demonic arm
the effects of the demon's power on
asta's arm are not going away
and his arm isn't going back to normal
owen says that he'd like to have a few
other healers take a look at asta's arm
but he
himself has never seen this phenomenon
before and he is unable to do anything
about it
gray also asks owen to take a look at
gauche's injuries
as you will recall gauche was pierced
clean through with one of dante's
gravity swords
and by every logical metric gauche
should not be alive
but when owen looks at gosh's chest he
can't believe that gauche was actually
stabbed with a sword at all
the injury has not only healed but
actually reconstructed itself
and this presumably means that grey's
magic didn't just heal gosh's injury but
reconstructed it in a way that makes it
as if he was never
injured in the first place owen suggests
that the true nature of grey's magic may
not be transformation
after all and i found this to be a very
interesting suggestion
i'm sure we'll get more details about
the true nature of grey's magic
in future chapters but from what we've
seen in this chapter
it seems that grey's magic may not be
transformation
but rather some form of reconstruction
theoretically
i would compare this to overhauls quirk
in boku no hero
for those of you who are familiar with
that series
it seems that grey's version of healing
magic doesn't function like
normal healing magic she didn't just
speed up
gauche's natural healing process she
seems to have reconstructed his body
in a way that makes it literally good as
new it's as if the injury had never even
taken place
this definitely reminds me of overhaul's
ability to deconstruct
and then reconstruct objects and people
and in particular
it reminds me of his ability to
reconstruct body parts in a way that not
only puts everything back together
but also gets rid of all the previous
illnesses and injuries that were
affecting this specific
body part the body part basically
becomes good as new
and this is seemingly what gray was able
to do with gauche although gray may not
be able to destroy
things in the same way that overhaul
does she may be able to reconstruct them
which would be an absolute game changer
for the black bulls if it turns out to
be true
imagine if grey can master this ability
and then use it to save the black bulls
from
injury or even death in future battles
this opens up so many new and awesome
possibilities for
black bull combat strategy and teamwork
i can't wait to find out more about the
true nature of grey's magic
if you have some opinions on her magic
and how it really works
definitely let me know down in the
comments below as expected vanessa
finrall and the other black bulls
are deeply upset about what happened to
yami but owen tells them that they need
to stop worrying about what to do now
and they need to get some rest
the magic knight captains are going to
meet in a few days
and they will determine what course of
action the clover kingdom is going to
take
next the chapter then skips to later
that night as
asta suddenly wakes up alone in bed his
demonic arm
moves and this seems to trigger a
reaction from his grimoire
the grimar opens and yami's katana
emerges from the book
the sword is rusty but it is clearly
exuding a dark
energy this scene implies that asta will
now be able to use yami's sword
permanently as one of his
swords which i have to say is pretty
freaking cool
although it is also kind of sad because
it reminds us that yami was kidnapped
and now he is no longer
able to use his own sword desperate to
save yami
asta runs outside and he seems to be
going somewhere
but then his body just stops moving and
he has no idea why
but then we can see that asta has
stepped into the shadow
of the secret black bull from the spade
kingdom
as you will recall the secret black ball
is a member of the black bulls who had
infiltrated the spade kingdom as a spy
we only saw this person very briefly and
we didn't see his or her face
but we did see that this person
possesses some sort of insanely cool
shadow magic and this magic allows its
user to disappear into shadows
and pull other people into their shadows
as well even though asta is desperate to
save yami
the secret black bull tells him that
this is impossible
asta could not defeat even one member of
the dark triad without yami's help
and there are three of them that he has
to deal with and this time he can't even
count on yami to protect him
in addition asta had been relying on the
anti-magic demon
during his fight against dante but now
even the demon has abandoned him
asta is simply too weak to access any
more of his anti-magic demon's power
what's more asta doesn't even know
what's going on with his arm
so basically he is trying to rescue yami
in a state of recklessness and ignorance
which is not a recipe for success asta
asks the stranger what he could possibly
know about asta
since asta has no idea who this person
is but the secret black bull explains
that he actually knows yami
very well by the way i am assuming that
the secret black bull is a man
based on his appearance and based on
tabitha's art style in terms of drawing
men versus women
but we haven't gotten a detailed look at
this person yet and we don't know the
details about them so we'll have to wait
for more information regarding their
gender the stranger says that yami is
rugged violent
insincere and a bunch of other things
and if yami ended up losing to the triad
that's his own fault for not being more
careful
asta gets mad when he hears this and he
summons the demon destroyer's sword and
the demon dweller's sword
but as asta attempts to attack the
stranger
dozens of dark demonic arms emerge from
the shadows
and they pin asta to the ground hosta
suddenly finds himself
face down on the ground and unable to
move
the stranger tells asta that if he can't
beat him
then he can't possibly hope to save yami
asta breaks down
and begins to sob he hates himself for
being so weak and he desperately wishes
to be stronger
the secret black bull tells asta that he
is stupid
but that he is also a good person the
stranger then proceeds to tell asta that
he likes him
and that yami is indeed alive
asta is shocked to see that the stranger
has a demon horn
growing above his eye and asta asks what
the hell
are you and that is how this insane
chapter ends
with the secret black bull finally
revealing himself or herself to asta
with the revelation that yami is still
alive
and with the implication that the secret
black ball might also be connected to
demon magic
now as of the making of this video there
are various competing translations and
there are also additional leaks whose
translation has not yet been confirmed
however according to some translations
the stranger does confirm that he is
indeed
the vice captain that his name is
knocked
which means knight in german and that he
can teach
asta how to fully master the power of
his demon
because knock himself is a demon magic
user
basically the secret black bull also has
his own demon slash
devil if the official translation
doesn't confirm this then i will address
it in a future video
but if we assume that this is indeed the
case then we just witnessed a massive
twist
in the story the vice captain of the
black bulls
apparently possesses some sort of demon
shadow magic
and he is about to help asta become even
stronger by teaching him how to master
the power of his own anti-magic demon
again if all of this proves to be
accurate it is an absolutely huge deal
for the black lover story
and i really want to find out more as
soon as possible
with all of that said it is important to
remember that having horns
doesn't necessarily mean that you are
possessed by a demon or that you have a
demon of your own
secret has horns as well and that is
because horns appear as a result of
using forbidden magic
nevertheless sacred's horns are
permanent whereas the secret black
bull's horns seem to grow
only when he wants them to and if the
currently available translations and
additional leaks can be trusted
the vice captain is not just a forbidden
magic user
but also a demon magic user just like
asta
and the dark triad i am extremely
interested in finding out how the secret
black bowl came across
this power and what type of person he is
and of course i am super curious about
how powerful this secret black bowl and
his shadow magic
truly is from what we've seen just in
this chapter
shadow magic looks like it is even more
powerful than any of us could have
imagined
definitely let me know what you guys
think about all of these crazy
developments
what is going to happen to asta's arm
and is his current condition going to
deteriorate
or is he going to be okay is this secret
black bull
a demon magic user and how powerful can
shadow magic possibly be finally
how are asta and the black bulls
including the secret black bull
going to rescue yami please don't forget
to share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black clover content right here on
the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime out pro or maybe you just
haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications i know it's a hassle
especially if you tend to watch youtube
without logging in but if you don't go
through the trouble of subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you're gonna miss a
ton of our videos
it's just how youtube works feel free to
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime emperor
patrons who make videos like this one
possible an extra special thank you to
alpha a disciple of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget are the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata
alolan adam the world steelers acquired
respect
pate heffer jonathan king brendan aviles
papa smurf emperor otaku thomas jones
and kin mono finally big thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
jason wilson king zeldris anatoly
kazatsky
angel crews cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci
alicia octor jessica kayla fond hinokami
and water
bonnie parks rothwin de ora deadly saint
and stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space
[Music]
cowboys
[Music]
you